a brand new dissonance 3 trailer was
showcased on Good Morning America on
April 5th 2019 and fans are even more
excited than before we'll walk you
through a rundown of the super short but
extremely jam-packed trailer stay tuned
to find out why we think Hades isn't as
bad as he seems
a great evil will have their revenge
descendants 3 is officially coming out
this summer and fans are losing it over
the franchise's newest trailer and we
really can't blame them the trailer
starts off by showing the 4 V K's
walking through the grounds of our Don
Pratt everyone is fast asleep and it
becomes clear that a major threat is
underway to make matters worse all of us
except her in the Queen's crown of
install we then get our first look at
Celia faseler who seems to be opening a
Cell and releasing Hades at some point
we even see Harry and uma looking a
little bit scared if they made a deal
with the facile ears then it's bound to
backfire on them sooner than later who
we believed to be Celia says the words a
great evil will have their revenge and
all in auradon will pay forever
we then see Hades who appears to be in
auradon running towards the gate he
sticks his head out of the barrier and
shoots a blue blast upwards from the
looks of things our favorite BK's
escapes from our dawn before the barrier
was closed for good next we hear mal say
the words the only thing more powerful
than the scepter is Hades umber so this
could only mean one thing the V K's need
to locate Hades and acquire his ember in
order to beat Ouma at her own game we
then see a mischievous looking Hades
twirling his ember between his fingers
he gives mal an evil look before the
scene cuts out his Hades about two hands
mal D ember or does he have something
else in mind many of us were startled to
see Audrey sound asleep in a bed with a
string of people around her we were led
to believe that Audrey would be one of
the three cools big bads
but now she seems to be the least of our
worries oddly enough we then see Hades
standing over her bed he seems to be
conjuring a spell but whether or not
this is to help her
remains to be seen if Audrey is indeed
cursed she'll need a true love's kiss to
set her free and if chad charming has in
fact the love of her life only he'll be
able to break the spell but wait did
Chad make it out of our time or is he
fast asleep like Audrey and everyone
else it's possible that Audrey is the
one behind the sleeping curse after all
she did look a little guilty when
everyone was going down we finally get a
good look at Celia and it's safe to say
that she's following in her father's
footsteps both dr. facile ear and his
daughter will be making appearances in
the movie however we've yet to see dr.
facile ear who will be played by actor
Jamal Sims in the flesh for now we're
led to believe that Celia is behind our
dongs misfortune could she be the one
who struck a deal with princess Aurora's
daughter if so it looks like history is
about to repeat itself Celia is clearly
showcased throwing her tarot cards in
the air and dancing around which could
mean that she's celebrating the victory
of some sorts her maniacal laugh is all
we need to hear to know that the girls a
villain unless I get that ember it's
game over so we were surprised to see
Ouma holding the amber in her hand with
the menacing look on her face this
strikes us as strange considering that
Hades was seen holding that same ember
at the beginning of the trailer is it
possible that Ouma has a fake ember or
did Hades really hand over our Don's
last hope to the enemy we're so confused
about Hades and Ouma we mean are they
good guys or bad guys although we're led
to believe that they're both villains
their allegiances can change at a
moment's notice
still mal could have been referring to
Hades when she said that someone was
draining her powers and despite getting
defeated by mal and her friends on
numerous occasions Ouma did warn now
that she'd never see her next attack
coming our Hades in Ouma working
together to destroy mouths rule will
have to wait and see throughout the
short trailer the words spells were made
to be broken
flash across the screen at first we were
more than a little confused but when we
saw the Isle of the lost barrier get
struck by a huge lightning bolt of magic
we finally understood what they meant by
the statement despite the fact that the
barrier prevents villains from escaping
were meant to be broken and so they have
been hundreds of angry villains will
undoubtedly escape from the aisle and
cause mayhem in our dime but who broke
the spell good Uma have used Hades ember
to free her people or is someone else
behind this gesture the trailer then
jumps to mal and her friends in the
woods a purple smoke clears to reveal
that mouths party has turned to stone so
now now has to face her enemies all on
her own
whoever is messing with mal Beulah Hades
Audrey Surya or everyone all at once one
thing is painfully clear they want to
watch his now loses everyone and
everything she loves whoa talk about a
personal vendetta the trailer concludes
in a very puzzling way we see an
angry-looking mal being engulfed by a
cloud of purpose smoke could now be
turned into a dragon or is she about to
unleash a power she's never used before
The Descendants three title flashes
across the screen only to confuse us
even more it's here that we see fassl
heirs tarot cards swirling in the wind
and it soon reveals that Hades as
picture is plastered onto the card so
what does this mean has Hades been
compromised or did he strike a deal with
Celia so that he can be released from
the Isle of the Lost only to be
imprisoned and our Don although Hades
might have started out as a villain he
might end up joining mouse fights to get
revenge on Celia what do you guys think
about this trailer let us know in the
comment section give this video a big
thumbs up if you can't wait to find out
whose side Hades is on and don't forget
to subscribe to the things so that you
never miss a video thanks for watching
we'll catch you next time